très attaché à cluny et à la saône et
loire c'est pourtant dans la nièvre que
françois mitterrand mènera toute sa
carrière d'élu local
parachuté dans le morvan il remporte sa
première élection en 1946 et les
législatives françois mitterrand devient
donc député de la nièvre hymne le
restera dans un premier temps 12 ans
jusqu'aux législatives de 1958 à
montsauche enfin dans la nièvre
monsieur mitterrand faisait partie les
338 députés sortants réélus
l'année suivante françois mitterrand est
élu sénateur de la nièvre un passage de
trois ans au palais du luxembourg avant
de retrouver le palais bourbon en 1962
en 1964 il défend à la tribune la force
de dissuasion absolue de la france
la parole est à monsieur mitterrand il
n'y a pas de dissuasion absolue gilles
agresseurs éventuels
c'est que l'armement français ne peut
lui poser que des dommages partielles
tandis que lui aurait anéantir notre
pays 1964 c'est aussi l'année de son
élection à la présidence du conseil
général de la nièvre
avant cela il est devenu maire de
château chinon ce sera son plus long
mandat d'élu de lanières il y est
attaché il lui permet de rester au plus
près du terrain et de la population
je suis maire de château finance depuis
c'est à cette tâche que je m'applique
essentiellement je suis ici en dépit de
mes obligations à paris et de mes
obligations dans toute la france au nom
du parti que je suis ici pratiquement
toutes les semaines il est très rare que
je manque à ce que je considère comme un
devoir à l'égard des habitants de
château chinon
en plus je me plais quand je viens ici
et je retrouve un vaste cercle d'amis je
retrouve des travaux concret et pratique
on voit ce qu'on fait on voit ce qu'on
construit parallèlement à cette carrière
nivernaise françois mitterrand se
prépare à d'autres desseins c'est en
1965 qu'il présente sa première
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
la france découvre alors un autre
françois mitterrand celui qui va
s'opposer au général de monsieur
françois mitterrand député de la nièvre
qui se présente comme le candidat de la
gauche à l'élection présidentielle a
tenu cet après midi une nouvelle
conférence de presse
je suis le candidat unique de la gauche
et je considère que toutes les
formations et tous les partis politiques
de la gauche et du centre gauche qui
m'ont fait l'honneur de me soutenir
honte à partir de là à accepter les
directions essentiel que je leur définit
un galop d'essai prometteur qui mettra
de gaulle en ballottage la tentative
suivante sera pour 1974 entre sa
circonscription nivernaise et sa mairie
de château chinon françois mitterrand
attend son tour